insofar as the liberal arts education
serves to form you as a person traveling
a girl is a rich and necessary part of
becoming a liberal educated person
because you see the application of what
it is you are learning to appreciate the
trip was a really cool combination of
the biblical sites and being exposed to
the geopolitical situation in Israel we
had a couple speakers every day who
lectured on topics that ranged from what
it's like to be a journalist in Israel
to the peace negotiations with the
Palestinians to some of the hurdles that
Israel faces at home and abroad on the
first day we escalated at a tilt and we
went down into a cave when we were
digging in basically the trash dump of
this ancient society which was a lot of
fun we went to both in Getty and Masada
in the same day and they're both out in
the desert looking over the Dead Sea and
in Getty is kind of a lush beacon where
there's waterfalls and trees in life
that you wouldn't expect to see in the
middle of the desert
the big takeaway for me for this trip in
my faith is the fact that now as I read
my Bible I'll be able to sit down and
picture in my mind all those places we
visited as I see their names in the
scripture itself the liberal arts really
have formed me to be able to process a
lot of what we saw on the trip and be
able to appreciate a lot of what we
experienced just the formation that I've
received in my education was invaluable
and being able to see the things that we
saw the way that I saw them
you